("Crazy Little Thing")
- I think Tim Tams bringing
out too many strange flavors
is an overkill 'cause I don't think
you can go past the original.
- I haven't actually tried
the other Tim Tam flavors.
- Oh, it's a total overkill.
- I feel like some of the
flavors are a bit out there.
- Oh, no.
- What?
- That Tim Tam is like what Nickleback is
to the music industry.
- Bum dirt.
- It tastes like an American biscuit.
- I'll give it a four out of five.
- I'm giving it a one.
- It's disturbing. Zero.
- Probably a three or a four.
- I'd say like a two and half.
- [Voiceover] This is the dark chocolate.
- What? No.
- Something I'd eat with my nan.
- This kinda just tastes
like a mint slice,
but without the mint.
- Three out of five.
- Three.
- A four.
- Three and a half.
- Two.
- One.
- [Man with Glasses] Mmmm.
- I don't like it.
I feel like it tastes
kind of like milk powder.
- I don't really wanna swallow it.
- Four out of five.
I'll give that four out of five.
- Four.
- Wow, zero.
- Two.
- I reckon four.
- One.
- Mmmm, yes.
- That's good.
- It smells like something
you put on your skin.
- Not good.
- My God, it gets better with time.
- A one, probably.
- A one?
- Yeah.
- One and a half.
- I'll give it a five.
- A three and a half.
- Probably a one and a half.
- 10 out of five.
Yeah!
- It tastes like off tiramisu.
- It's just beautiful.
- Tastes like fake coffee though.
- I think they could have (beep) it up,
but that's pretty good.
- I'm gonna give it a three.
- That's a zero.
- That might be a zero out of five.
- 3.5.
Can I do that?
- Two and a half probably.
- A five out of five.
- Kinda doesn't taste of anything.
- I don't hate it.
- It's not offensive.
- No, it's not.
It doesn't really taste like anything.
- It kinda feels like a
chocolate covered Monte Carlo.
- I'm gonna give it the middling
score of three out of five.
- Yeah, I agree, three.
- I would give this one a three.
- One and a half out of five.
- Really?
- [Man in Glasses] Yeah.
- That's really harsh.
- I'm brutal.
- I'd give it a five.
- Three and a half.
- The caramel compliments
like the straight
dairy milk chocolate really well.
- Who doesn't like a
chewy caramel substance
in their mouth?
- Three and a half.
- I'll give it a four.
- I'll probably give that a four as well.
- A four?
- Yeah.
- I'd say a five.
- Four.
- I'm gonna go with a two.
- Mmmm, yes.
- That is just the best.
- This the way of the future.
- You can't complain with extra chocolate,
so it's a solid four
and a half out of five.
- Five out of five, easy.
- Five.
- I'll give it a four out of five.
- 20 out of five.
- Woah!
- If I can do that.
- Yeah, I'd give it a five as well.
(drum roll)
(crowd cheering)
("Crazy Little Thing")